he's alive it could have been a lot  worse he's giving up his rook for a  bishop so black's bishop light squad  bishop can take that rook in the center  but then the white knight will leap into  the middle and suddenly the white knight  is actually really active but also  digging the music here minus do is he  poker facing chakariar mamadiaro here  trying to tell him that yeah no  i hate my position  shaking his head but actually feeling  kind of confident now and  oh wow mama  and blunder from mama jarov  he's blundered and magnus has got out of  jail  majora forgot that the white rook could  save itself and come across with a check  and black's rook next is going to drop  mamajora resigns magnus wins  huge turnaround oh my  chess god that is  such a huge turn of events magnus  carlsen it was looking horrible for him  he ends up winning the first  blitz game how is he feeling now lucky  excited relieved yeah confused yeah wow  i mean i don't think he's even got